his name. We've mentioned it before.
Abu Saeed al-Khudri.
Somebody tells me his name, I'll
quit and leave town. What do you think?
[Arabic recitation]
Okay, he narrates that the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam said,
"Yakhruju al-Dajjal.
Fayatawajjahu qibalahu rajulun min
al-mu'minin.
Fayatalqaahu al-masalih. Masalih
al-Dajjal. Al-masalih hum ya'ni
al-musallahin
alladhina yakununa 'ala
atraf al-madinah.
Wahum al-tala'i' wal-haras.
Fahadha yakhruju yuridu al-Dajjal.
Fayumsiku fihi min? Haras al-Dajjal
wa-haras hudud al-Dajjal. Fayakhudhuhu
al-masalih.
Qala fayakuluna lahu, "Ila ayna ta'mid?"
Ya'ni ila ayna tadhhab turid? Fayakulu,
"A'midu ila hadha alladhi kharaja."
Fayakuluna lahu, "Awama tu'minu
birabbina?"
Wahadha yadullu 'ala annahu
yaz'umu annahu
rabbul 'alamin. Wal-'iyadhu billah.
Wayad'u al-nas li'ibadatih.
Fahuwa min tawaghit al-tarikh.
So, in this narration, our Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam narrates that
al-Dajjal will emerge upon the earth.
And a man
from amongst the believers
will head to go and meet al-Dajjal. And
he will be caught by the
He will be caught by the
guards that are on the
you know, they're checkpoints.
what we would have checkpoints
today where they are monitoring the
borders of any town. So, he has
troops he has, and these
you know, these troops will catch him
while he is on his way to come and find
the jet.
And so, they will ask him, "Where are
you going?"
He will say, "I am
headed to meet and see for myself this
man."
And they will say, "Are you saying that
you do not believe in our Lord?"
So, he's going to be calling people
and inviting people to worship him, to
believe in him as as their creator, as
their God, as their Lord, right?
And
there is a narration which is in a
sunan.
The narration has weakness in its chain
that when he first emerges, he will
claim to be just a righteous person
calling to Allah.
And then over time,
he will
claim to be a prophet.
And then after that, he will claim to be
al-Masih Isa ibn Maryam. And then after
that, he will claim to be
Allah himself. Wa al-iyadhu billah. Now,
this narration is weak in its chain of
narration, but it is fathomable
due to the fact that this is usually how
people this
usually
go into darkness. They don't go all at
[Arabic recitation]
al-Shaytan. They usually do not call
people and invite people right away to
that. Usually, they start with
you know, steps. They take it
incrementally.
But, because they feel
they are
entitled,
can you ever satisfy
the
hunger of someone who is entitled?
Someone feels entitled. Can you ever
satisfy them? Impossible.
It's impossible to satisfy entitlement.
As a matter of fact, the more you feed
entitlement, the worse it gets.
And so,
you notice this trend
with false prophets, cult leaders,
right? When they usually come out, they
come out piggybacking on some mainstream
religion. And they will start to branch
off slowly. And then their claims will
become more and more intense, and their
demands from their followers will become
more and more severe. Why? Because
they're trying to feed a monster that's
inside of them that's never going to be
satisfied. And so, they will say our
master will be our master.
Yanni, Allah Azza wa Jall
[Arabic recitation]
yakhfa ala ibadihi mithla hadha.
Yaqulu fa yaquluna uqtulu.
Fa yaqulu ba'duhum li ba'din, alaysa qad
nahakum rabbukum an taqtulu ahadan
dunahu? Yanni, biduni idhnihi.
Fa yantaliqūna bihi ila ad-dajjal. Fa
idha ra'ahu al-mu'minu qala ya ayyuhan
nas, inna hadha ad-dajjal
alladhi dhakara Rasul Allah sallallahu
[Arabic recitation]
bihi fayushabbah yushabbah ya'ni
tufraq
[Arabic recitation]
So
in this narration
he says that when these
security
catches this man, they'll say, "Where
are you going?" He'll say, "I'm going to
meet this man that is making all of
these claims." They will say, "Are you
saying that you do not believe in our
God and our Lord?" He will say,
"Our Lord, Allah, God, is not
hidden, is not so
is not is not so
is not so obscure
for some people to Look, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala, his message is clear, his
prophets are clear, right?
And so, some of them will say, "Kill
this man."
And others will say, "Wait, he's told
you
that you are not allowed to kill anyone
without his permission."
And so, they will take him to a Dajjal.
And so, when he is brought to a Dajjal,
as soon as he sees him, he will notice
the signs
and the traits that the Prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam informed us
of about a Dajjal.
And what is the most prominent of his
traits that differentiates him
and what is his most prominent
hallmark that lets us know he is a
Dajjal?
Yes, Faisal. He will have on his
forehead written
kaf kafir, right.
Kaf fa ra, so three letters,
but it is pronounced kafir.
Because in Arabic shorthand, the alif is
the alif is not written out it is
in modern Arabic. So,
it's written in front on his
forehead, kafir. Every believer will see
it. What's his second most prominent
trait?
His eye. His eye.
And
what is his third most prominent trait?
His hair.
Those are it, but his third most
prominent trait is that he will claim to
be Allah.
Now,
so these things converge, this is a
Dajjal.
And so,
he will, upon hearing this, when he
comes in and he sees a Dajjal, he will
say, "People, this is
the Dajjal
that
the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam has warned you about. This is
him."
The people that are there entertaining
him and his courtiers, and
he will say, "Ayyuha an-nas,
this is a Dajjal."
A Dajjal is often translated as the
Antichrist, right?
And it's an acceptable
translation in the sense that he will be
anti
against the Isa ibn Maryam alayhis
salaam, but it's not a very good
translation. The translation is a
Dajjal, meaning the
the great liar.
Right? The great liar. This is really
the
better translation.
And so, a Dajjal upon hearing this
will
tell his people to take this man and to
tie him up
and
open up his
his limbs, spread his limbs out, tie him
up.
[Silence]
And so, as they take him
take hold of him
they will he will then say, "Beat this
man." And so, they will start to beat
him in his back and in his stomach.
And then he will ask him again, the
Dajjal will ask this man, "Oh, am I to
believe in you do you not believe in me
now?"
This is the second greatest evidence
that this person has not come from
Allah. Never has Allah sent a person
to represent him
and to call to him by beating people
into submission.
This is not
the hallmark of prophets. This is not
the hallmark of messengers.
So, he's going to have him beat silly
and then he's going to say, "How about
now? Do you believe in me now?
Right?"
And so,
the man will only double down and he
will say,
"You are the
great traveled
the wide traveled or the globe-trotting
liar." If you really wanted to translate
it accurately.
So, the globe-trotting
you are al-Masih ad-Dajjal.
[Silence]
And so, then he will have him tied
up, and he will bring out a saw, and he
will have him sawed sawed into two
halves.
From the top of his head
all the way down through his groin,
between his legs.
[Silence]
And so, he will have
[Arabic recitation]
And so, he will have this man sawed into
two halves.
Ad-Dajjal will then walk between the two
halves.
And then he
will say,
"Stand up."
And the man will then
come back together and stand up before
him.
[Arabic recitation]
me?"
So, if the beating didn't help, now I've
cut you in half and put you back
together. Now do you believe in me?"
And he will say, "Mazdadtu
I am even more sure that you are
ad-Dajjal. Now I'm I'm definitely sure.
I I am only more positive that you are
ad-Dajjal."
[Arabic recitation]
have a regimen. Yeah, cool. Yeah, I will
not. You know, that.
I'm a half.
I know how that.
I can shake. I will soon.
I can I can I can. I got you cool. I
can.
I can wait. I can. I can. I can I can I
can. I can I can I can.
I can I can I can. I can I can I can. I
can I can I can. I can I can I can.
I can. I can. I can I can I can. I can I
can I can. I can. I can. I can I can I
can.
I can. I can. I can I can I can.
I can.
I can. I can I can.
I can. I can I can I can I can I can. I
can.
I can. I can.
I can I can.
I can I can I can.
I can. I can. I can I can I can I can I
can. I can I can I can.
I can.
I can. I can I can I can.
I can I can I can.
I can. I can. I can.
I can. I can. I can I can I can.
I can.
I can I can I can. I can I can I can I
can I can I can. I can.
I can. And so.
[Arabic recitation]
do you now believe in me? And he will
say, I am only more sure now and only
more certain that you are a Dajjal, the
great liar that our prophet salallahu
alayhi wasallam informed us of.
And then he will say, oh people,
do not be afraid anymore because I am
the last person he will ever do this to.
And so a Dajjal,
you know, he he he has lost at every
turn of this debate.
So, when falsehood is cornered, what
does it do?
It uses violence, right? They always
make this the Muslimeen or the
people of the truth are the ones that
resort to violence first. Not true.
It is falsehood that resorts to violence
to defend itself when it's cornered.
And so,
[Arabic recitation]
throw him into his fire.
And so, people will think that he has
been thrown into the fire because the
Dajjal has a river of fire and a river
of water. Well, people will think that
he was thrown into the fire. It's an
illusion. People will see the body go
into the fire, they will see him burn,
they will smell the scent. It will look
he was thrown into fire, but in
reality,
he was entered and thrown into paradise.
The prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam
has said that this man will be the
greatest of all martyrs with Allah
rabbul alameen on the day of judgement.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]